riley's in los angeles hey riley welcome
to the ramsay show
dave chris thank you so much for taking
my call tomorrow honor to talk to you
how can we help
uh so my girlfriend and i uh we found a
house that we really like
um we went through the pre-approval
process this morning
but i'm just i'm having a really hard
time it's a huge amount of money and i'm
trying to determine
whether we can afford it or not well
when's the wedding date
uh that that's coming really soon uh not
not a date set yet but uh
in the near future the closing would
need to occur after that
okay you're setting yourself up for a
very very dangerous scenario otherwise
from a legal perspective and from a
relational perspective
both um it feels harmless
and like you're but you're just getting
things out of order
because in 30 years of doing coaching
chris and i have seen
um heartbreaking situations and uh
horrifying situations where
you basically from a legal perspective
what you're doing is you're entering
into a general partnership with no
partnership documents
and so an example would be um
god forbid uh something happened and uh
she died in a car wreck now you own a
house with her mother
because you're not the heir you're not
the heir
and or she becomes permanently disabled
uh and you now own the house with
someone you're not married to
um and you might go ahead and get
married in that case you might not i
don't know
i i mean there's a lot of variables in
those situations
but the uh you know you might uh you
know or
or something happens to the relationship
now you've got this
bad breakup but you do not have a legal
forum
which a divorce gives you to deal with
the property involved yeah
because you don't have any partnership
documents yeah so please don't buy a
house
yeah riley don't do that and i'll tell
you this dave another thing i just did a
media hit today
talking about the home buying market and
he made mention he's not comfortable
with that dollar amount
well first and foremost don't do that
yeah and so i was walking through
you know people are letting the low
interest rate and the low
inventory of homes caused them to rush
in to buy
and lady uh overpaying overpaying she
forgot
she for didn't deleted having to have
the home inspection done
bought a home that was riddled with
black mold
oh and so there's there's just steps you
need to take so i want a
teachable moment for everybody out there
when you're ready to buy a home you are
completely out of debt
you've got an emergency fund you you've
got a down payment minimum of 10
i'd love you to have 20 yeah you're
either buying it as a single person or
married but not with your girlfriend
that's right
20 down payment well allows you to avoid
pmi
private mortgage insurance which adds
hundreds of dollars to your payment
doesn't protect you it protects the
lender and you also need to have money
available to take care of the closing
costs which can be three to five percent
of the loan balance
so you got to have a clear plan not to
mention boundaries on what type of home
you're looking for
and how much you're going to spend and
when you get in a hurry oh man and you
get
you get house fever yep you're getting
ready to overpay and buy a house with
black mole because you didn't get the
debt camera
inspector inspection and that's why a
few hundred dollars all right
circling back to raleigh for just a
second so riley
what you've done is a up until now
is a good healthy normal process you're
dating someone that you're about to get
engaged to it sounds like
um according to your own words and you
guys are out riding around the weekend
looking at houses and you're dreaming
about your future
and i i grew up in the real estate
business i still ride around look at
houses even if i don't need one
i just i love real i like going out
looking at property i like seeing
what's developing somewhere where
they're putting up this or that and
uh um you know and sharon and i've done
that for 40 years of marriage
you know we just go out if there's an
open house we'll just walk through it
and look at them oh look at what they're
doing with those kitchens these days you
know that kind of stuff and
you know it's a good thing to dream
about your future and
kind of look at that and visualize
yourself owning a house together living
together
in a marriage situation moving forward
all of those things are healthy and
normal
uh it just escalated to where one thing
the
the the wrong thing got in front uh the
old saying the cart before the horse
and don't buy a house till you're
married with someone
and so um any more than you buy a house
with your college roommate
if that didn't give you a shiver down
there's fine no
so yeah that's that's my suggestion to
you sir and
i do want you to have a house i want you
to have a wonderful future with this
young lady and i just don't want
uh all the part of the thing that we
learn about people building wealth is
they play offense but you also play
defense yes
and doing things in the right order is a
defensive move
and so buying a home with someone you're
married to is
versus someone you live with is a
defensive move
because it's defending you against the
possibility of a stupid situation coming
up
and leaving you looking and feeling
stupid yep that's true
because dave sometimes people can become
crazy
[Laughter]
crazy
not riley's girlfriend no no her not her